elle que les ans tu es plus calme que ce
qui se passait sur le ring tout de même
notre débat sur l'avenir de l'assurance
chômage juste avant l'ouverture lundi
des négociations sur le sujet avec
christophe sirugue député ps sandrine
mourey secrétaire de la cgt de côte-d'or
pierre antoine karam président du medef
bourgogne et guillaume maillard
conseiller régional udi on poursuit
notre débat tout à l'heure avec une
autre piste qu'on n'a pas évoqué que
certains évoquent actuellement les
fonctionnaires ne cotisent pas pour
l'unedic ainsi que les travailleurs
indépendants
est ce que ce serait une bonne idée ou
est-ce que c'est complètement supplie de
christophe sirugue et thématique est
simple c'est que si vous introduisez des
nouveaux éléments dans la discussion
vous les uns trop divisés en recettes et
en dépenses ou les intronisés pas c'est
pas un élément comment j'allais dire
qu'ils se capitaliser dans un sens et
puis qui éviterait la dénomination dans
l'autre donc encore une fois
moi je me méfie toujours de cette
comparaison entre le système public et
le système privé ils ont été construits
sur des bases très différentes mais
toutes les études montrent que ce qu'on
nous explique comme étant des avantages
ne sont pas forcément au bout du compte
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit
prudent là dessus pour moi le système
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui doit être
maintenue modifié probablement sur des
éléments mais il faut pas tout
introduire c'est quand vous avez envie
de faire disparaître un système vous
mettez tout dedans comme ça vous avez
une implosion et on passe ensuite à
autre chose je ne sais pas ce que serait
autre chose il va se passer quoi
apparence même sur sur la suite
1 parce que on regarde l'assurance
chômage avec des plus et des moins
comment on pourrait introduire vous
venez de dire d'autre chose
l'unedic le dit clairement dans son
rapport on peut très vite combler le
déficit de l'unedic avec une relance de
l'emploi
pardonnez-moi la cour des comptes dès le
contre mais non mais dans son rapport
oui mais le combat ça pourrait très vite
être comblés avec un rien
un retour un retour à l'emploi je
reviendrai quand même sur les aides
publiques vous ne voulez pas mais je
compte bien mettre tout de même des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place par
ce gouvernement au nom de l'emploi
pas plus de responsabilités cic est
également on les oublie les exonérations
de cotisations ces dispositifs sont mis
en place sur des aides aux entreprises
aide publique soit disant au nom de
l'emploi au nom la résorption du chômage
exemple nous avons eu les mêmes chiffres
à la réunion sera le comité de suivi
régional du cic je suis force à 2015 en
bourgogne 1,2 milliard dettes publiques
aux entreprises 1,2 milliard en
bourgogne sur trois dispositifs
cotisations exonérations de cotisations
cice et pacte de responsabilité 1,2
milliard au bout du compte chiffres du
chômage plus 6,6 6400 demandeurs
d'emploi en plus donc vous pourrez bien
comprendre que nous ont abandonnés
organisations syndicales on se dise que
cet argent public
il doit servir à l'emploi le un million
d'emplois malheureusement sur un chiffre
bourguignon on se rend compte que malgré
ses 1,2 milliard qui pourrait comme
servir à créer des emplois a bien
investi ssements productif augmenter les
serres et bien cet argent là il a au
bout du compte pas bénéficié à l'emploi
plus 6400 demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires donc il ya une je pense
qu'il faut aussi responsabiliser les
employeurs sur les aides publiques qu'il
gagne 1,2 milliard en bourgogne c'est
pas rien tout de même
et bien qu'au bout du compte il y est
quand même une baisse du taux de chômage
comme s'y était engagé
monsieur gattaz à l'époque des aides
publiques donc il faut créer de l'emploi
pour forer big ben l'évidence pour le
pays ce serait une bonne chose de créer
d'emplois pour ça faut créer les
conditions favorables
j'aurais juste répondre à l'amour et sur
une chose quand elle parle de ses 40
milliards g comme préciser tout à
l'heure qu'on revenait simplement au
niveau de 2010 au coeur et on était déjà
âgé la feuille là le taux de prélèvement
la france va y était déjà en tête en
des prélèvements obligatoires en europe
donc on revient à un niveau qui était
déjà pas satisfaisant mais je vous
rassure c'est 40 milliards dont vous
parlez que d'être public
c'est déjà de l'argent des entreprises
donc qui est passé dans la moulinette de
l'état devient de l'argent public pour
passer de l'argent d'aller des
contributions des entreprises pour
l'essentiel mais surtout des entreprises
alors pour revenir au sujet qui nous
intéresse malgré tout il y à une inertie
dans l'économie il faut que vous
compreniez savez je vous invite en stage
dans mon entreprise mal d'amour et parce
que vous vous verrez qu'on décrète pas
comme ça parce que on reçoit un moment
donné il ya une baisse à mon bonnet sur
lies parce que c'est donc sur lie à ce
que le cx se concrétise c'est à dire
qu'il ya comme un décalage dans la co
société
il faut d'abord prendre conscience de
cette baisse dit est ce parce que si
l'expert comptable ou votre comptable ne
vous met pas en évidence ce point là
bien vous pouvez tout à fait passer au
travers et puis constater
qu'effectivement peut-être ça représente
l'ours a présenté 4 % de la masse
salariale brute ça va passer à 6 % très
bien c'est une bonne chose mais c'est
pas ça qui va faire que vous allez
déclencher la le lendemain même à
l'emploi il ya tout un contexte et dans
ce contexte il faut aussi améliorer je
crois que c'est là le l'enjeu de la loi
de la mike comrie plus de souplesse sur
le droit de vous amener sur le sujet
parce que je le disais en ouverture on
avait prévu ce débat sur l'unedic parce
que ça commence lundi et puis depuis
trois jours c'est la loi la préparation
de la loi travail qui est en train de
faire une sorte de deux déflagrations
est-ce que ça va peser sur les déclas
sur les discussions de l'unedic de votre
point de vue christophe sirugue cette
loi et puis dites nous quand même
en quelques mots ce que vous en pensez
on va pas trahir de secrets vous étiez
pressenti pour la rapporter pour être le
rapporteur de cette loi en l'état vous
le seriez en l'état du texte tel qu'il a
été envoyé au conseil d'état non je ne
saurais rapporteur que si la discussion
que j'ai engagée avec le gouvernement
mais laisse à penser qu'il ya une vraie
marge de discussions pour le parlement
pour l'instant je n'ai pas ces éléments
mais en l'état actuel il me semble que
le texte est trop déséquilibré pour
pouvoir être satisfaisante et qu'il est
présenté aujourd'hui
cela étant il faut bien qu'on analyse ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur les
nouvelles formes d'emploi il faut bien
qu'on analyse des problématiques qui
nous sont proposés dans les tpe pme
je parle bien des petites entreprises
car imaginez que il ne faut rien toucher
ce serait une vraie erreur par rapport
au contexte où n'ai rien touché
d'une part et fragilisé des dispositifs
entier qui sont ceux que l'on connaît
mme semblent être deux écueils dans
lesquels moi je ne souhaite pas je ne
souhaite pas cela étant vous avez
aujourd'hui une analyse qui me paraît un
peu un peu surprenante
on essaie de faire jouer au code du
travail un rôle qui n'est pas le sien
le code du travail n'est pas fait pour
créer ou pas des emplois il est fait
pour réguler la relation entre un
salarié et son employeur parce que c'est
comme ça il y avait un lien de
subordination comme on dit et qui est
réel donc le code du travail les faits
pour ça à côté de ça vous avez bien
évidemment des dispositifs qui sont
nécessaires qui doivent être pris en
compte sur les moyennes négocier sur les
moyens donnés à ceux qui négocient sur
les accords de branche sur la hiérarchie
des normes qui sont des enjeux pour moi
fondamentaux mais encore une fois oui il
faut avancer
oui il faut probablement assouplir les
choses mais encore une fois faut pas que
ce soit exclusivement au détriment des
statuts des salariés aujourd'hui donc
cette discussion elle est partie je les
ai quasiment tous les jours en ce moment
avec les représentants du gouvernement
et on verra ce qu'il en sera
au bout du compte ici le début mars
dites-nous quelque chose qui vient de la
colline et puis il ya manière à préparer
pour moi qui viens de la coulisse c'est
quoi la température des députés
socialistes ans ces derniers jours sur
ce texte
je pense qu'ils sont très perplexe par
rapport à ces textes ils sont répétées
perpétrées raison que j'évoquais c'est
que je crois qu'ils ont compris qu'il
fallait avancer sur la discussion dans
l'entreprise parce que c'est un enjeu
important mais en même temps on a là des
propositions sur les licenciements qui
sont quand même des propositions
extrêmement rude extrêmement sévère on a
on sacralise les 35 heures en même temps
objectivement on ouvre des portes qui
sont d'époque de remise en cause des 35
heures donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
redonne du sens à ce que l'on veut faire
par rapport à un contexte particulier
pain pour une évolution qui est réel et
redonner du sens c'est me semble-t-il
mettre des jaloux et ses jalons me
semble trop aujourd'hui
trouble pour pouvoir faire que
l'ensemble des parlementaires
socialistes puissent se retrouver dans
ce texte
guillaume maillard modifier le code du
travail droit du travail de votre point
de vue libéralisé c'est une bonne
solution
j'ai passé une bonne solution
monsieur a échappé la réponse d'autres
questions étaient est ce que le
financement de l'unedic et quelque part
lié à ce projet de loi n comme limogés
je suis resté à cette question ou qui
n'a pas forcément été clarifiée moi j'ai
passé trois revenus je pense que le
sujet est vraiment global quand cette
libéralisation du travail où cette
remise en question du code du travail je
pense qu'une fois de plus pour reprendre
des termes un peu un peu facile oeil
ndic est en train de se fissurer je
pense que faut pas le prendre mal il
faut le prendre comme une évolution de
la société par l'état leur de
numérisation de la société on veut que
le monde change
on voit que l'angleterre se pose
beaucoup de questions sur l'europe on
voit qu'il ya une europe aujourd'hui qui
a mis à mal aussi un système français un
système d'indemnisation un système de
travail
cette europe économique cette europe
sociale elle en est où
ce sac l'unedic l'assurance chômage / je
sais que le système français est très
spécifique sur son côté assurantielle
voitures anciennes
par contre quel rôle peut jouer l'europe
demain dans ce financement n'y at il pas
une idée d'un socle et d'assurance
seraient des lendemains elles nous
demandent de rembourser parce que c'est
ce qu'on n'a pas évoqué mais le
gouvernement veut 800 millions
d'économies pour être dans les clous des
3 3% de déficit public
oui on n'avait pas dit encore oui par
contre l'europe
on l'a vu hier soir l'europe n'a pas n'a
pas tout pouvoir les états sont
souverains les parlements sont
souverains il ya des lois nationales qui
sont à prendre en compte qu'il ya le
peuple aussi aidé à prendre en compte
on voit que les problématiques liées à
l'emploi sont beaucoup plus complexes qu
un simple code du travail un mot tendre
et bref sur négociations globales
l'unedic code du travail tout ça c'est
la même chose non il ya sacré par contre
un contexte troublant effectivement je
suis d'accord
on veut faire jouer au code du travail
un rôle qui n'est pas le sien à qui
va-t-on faire croire qu en assouplissant
les règles en faisant en sorte que les
salariés moins de droits dans
l'entreprise
on va résorber le chômage déjà déjà dans
le code du travail actuel il y a déjà de
nombreuses possibilités laissées aux
chefs d'entreprises de pouvoir se
séparer
d'ailleurs si la fameuse épaisseur du
code du travail et du la plupart du
temps à des dérogations suis désolé de
vous couper la fin de cette émission
ways beaucoup plus désolé non c'est
terminé ça va être le générique et
antoine thiers merci à tous les cas
d'être venus débattre samedi prochain le
débat portera sur l'agriculture au
moment de l'ouverture du salon bon week
end leur voix